I'm in good company here this week for
the agenda but who said the following
when the whole world is silent even one
voice becomes powerful was it Nelson
Mandela Sakharov Prize winner in 1988 or
was it Burmese opposition politician
unsung suchi no these were the words of
a now 16 year old school girl who has
become a household name Malala yousufzai
was shot in the head by the Taliban in
2012 just for going to school and on
Wednesday she will be awarded the
Parliament sakharov prize at a special
ceremony as the prize itself celebrates
its 25th anniversary farmers will be
very interested in the budget decisions
the Common Agricultural Policy is almost
as old as the EU itself and has gone
through various makeovers over the years
this summer emmy peas decided on another
reform which is a long time in the
making it claims it will make food more
affordable and agriculture greener mep s
are set to vote on it next wednesday
though it may meet some resistance from
environmentalists who feel the Green
Deal was watered down it was a case of
deal or no deal in Brussels this week as
EU decision makers thrashed out a
compromise on the 2014 budget well into
the night they finally agreed on 130 5.5
billion euros that's a six percent
decrease from 2013 but it's nor point
five billion euros more than austerity
minded EU leaders had wanted to spend
the main change is who will get their
hands on the money more will go to
research and innovation and less will
find its way to the regions as part of
the cohesion policy MEP s will have
their final say on the 2014 budget and a
vote on Wednesday as well as on the
longer-term budget up to 20 20 studying
abroad means you could learn a new
language and improve your chances of
landing your dream job in another
country the Parliament wants to give EU
students a leg up with its erasmus+
programme a new loan guarantee system
will offer cheap loans for those wishing
to get their master's degree abroad and
the system will be open to sports people
for the first time tune in on Tuesday to
find out more on the vote
I think that's as good a place as any to
wish you a great week and see you in
Strasburg